bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur la
chaîne de vulgarisation des instances
politiques
la chaîne qui vous explique en 5 10
minutes les détails des instances
politiques en france
aujourd'hui nous allons parler des
partis politiques qu'est ce que c'est
finalement un parti politique au sens
juridique un parti politique c'est une
association c'est à dire une
organisation de personnes au service
d'une idée commune et dont le but n'est
pas de partager des bénéfices le parti
politique recherche la réalisation de
ces idées à la conquête et l'exercice du
pouvoir
il permet l'expression des suffrages
c'est à dire des voix des citoyens et
peut se former librement
donc on n'a pas besoin d'autorisation
préalable pour le créer du moment qu'ils
respectent les principes de la
république un parti politique doit être
déclarée en préfecture et la déclaration
publiée au journal officiel des
associations pour avoir une capacité
juridique c'est-à-dire pour acquérir des
droits et les devoirs qui vont avec
au sens de la loi on dit qu'un parti
politique est une personne morale de
droit privé c'est à dire un groupement
des personnes réunies pour accomplir
quelque chose en commun et qui se soumet
à l'ensemble des règles de droit
applicables aux personnes et aux
antilles comme les associations ou les
autres pour être vu comme un parti
politique en tant que telle
l'association dont le but est politique
doit respecter les textes relatifs au
financement des partis politiques ainsi
que ceux relatifs à la transparence
financière de la vie politique
d'accord alors voyons un peu ce que
disent les textes et commençons par
parler des lois régissant le financement
des partis politiques
ceux ci peuvent être de deux types
publics et privés d'abord parlons des
financements publics
aujourd'hui il y a deux critères qui
permettent à un parti d'obtenir une aide
publique sachant que les deux peuvent
s'ajouter le premier c'est le résultat
aux élections législatives les partis
qui ont présenté des candidats qui ont
obtenu au moins 1% des voix dans 50
circonscriptions reçoit une aide
publique proportionnellement au nombre
de suffrages c'est à dire au nombre de
voix qu a obtenu chaque candidat une
autre partie de l'aide publique est
attribuée aux parties
proportionnellement au nombre de députés
et sénateurs qui sont influents rappelé
pour donner un exemple entre 2007 et
2012 chat devoir apporter aux partis
politiques environ 1 euro soixante dix
par an et chaque parlementaire environ
44 mille euros par an il faut savoir que
si la parité homme femme n'est pas
respectée lors de la présentation des
candidats aux élections les partis
politiques sont pénalisés financièrement
voyons maintenant les possibilités de
financement privé le premier type vient
des cotisations des adhérents et d'aisé
celles ci sont généralement d'un montant
peu élevé et ne suffisent pas à faire
face aux dépenses des partis politiques
le deuxième type de financement privé
autorisé ce sont les dons des personnes
privées limité à 7500 euros par personne
et pas ils sont souvent retenues au
moment des élections est rarement le
cadre normal du fonctionnement des
partis toujours de personne morale peut
être dire des entreprises ou des
associations ou encore dexia nation
indiqua ou collectivités locales sont
interdits pour éviter les financements
occultes ou les pressions provenant de
grandes puissances financières également
le financement complémentaire par des
micro partis est interdite effectivement
il existe en france une multitude de
micro partis qui peuvent être des partis
locaux ou associé à une personnalité
politique
ceux ci n'ont pas forcément pour
objectif d'obtenir des élus et donc du
financement public avant 2013
il pouvait servir à recueillir des
financements privés via des dons de
sympathisants pour apporter un
financement complémentaire aux grands
partis jusqu'à 2013 une personne pouvait
donner plusieurs fois le montant
autorisé à plusieurs partis différents
appartenant à la même sphère politique
depuis c'est interdit on ne peut pas
donner plus de 7500 euros par an en tout
que ce soit un parti politique ou à
plaisir longtemps qu'on a vu les règles
concernant le financement des partis
politiques
on peut voir celle qui concerne la
transparence de la vie politique
française pour recevoir l'ensemble de
ces fonds le parti politique doit soit
créer une association de financement qui
servira uniquement à recueillir ses
financements
soit désigné un mandataire financier
c'est-à-dire une personne physique qui a
une procuration pour agir au nom du
parti politique et qui sera déclarée en
préfecture
les dépenses de campagne doivent être
récapitulé dans un compte de campagne et
certifié par un expert comptable puis
transmis à la commission nationale des
comptes de campagne et des financements
politiques pour vérification la
commission sera vérifié que les partis
politiques respectent la loi concernant
leur financement et leurs comptes de
campagne lors des différentes élections
le juge de l'élection permet également
de contrôler l'ensemble des comptes de
campagne il s'agit du conseil
constitutionnel pour les élections
présidentielle et législatives et du
juge administrative lors des autres
élections
il faut savoir que le montant des bus
aux campagnes électorales pour les
élections au suffrage universel direct
est plafonné les partis politiques
pourront aussi certaines obligations en
matière de comptabilité
ils doivent tenir une comptabilité
arrêtés leur point cette année les faire
certifier par deux commissaires aux
comptes et déposer les comptes de
l'année elle moins un an au plus tard le
30 juin de l'année
enfin les élus doivent déclarer l'état
de leur patrimoine en début et en fin de
mandat pour éviter qu'ils sont réussis
personnellement pendant cette période la
déclaration se fait auprès de la haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique en relation avec
l'administratrice call française
voilà maintenant on peut se demander
quel est le rôle des partis politiques
le rôle essentiel est de participer à
l'animation de la vie politique via les
idées qui vont apporter
ils ont également d'autres fonctions
telles que la définition d'orientations
et de l'onu pour le pays où la localité
via un programme
la structuration de l'opinion publique
par l'animation du débat politique
la sélection des candidats et des élites
politiques et au niveau national ils
sont également l'intermédiaire entre le
peuple et le gouvernement le parti
élabore un programme avec ses
propositions si le parti l'emportent
ces propositions devraient être reprises
dans le projet du gouvernement des
partis d'opposition dont ceux qui n'ont
pas emporté l'élection peuvent rapporter
le mécontentement de certains électeurs
via la proposition d'autres projets
question organisation
le parti politique s'organise comme il
veut il n'y a pas de règle là dessus
mais pour être efficace et mettre en
place le programme politique que les
membres du parti ont élaboré tous les
partis ont un texte constitutif qui
définit leur organisation interne
en général les parties d'envergure
nationale se réunissent périodiquement
en congrès pour permettre aux différents
courants du parti de discuter et
débattre aussi tous les partis nationaux
ou un bureau ou conseil national avec au
sommet un président ou un secrétaire
national
souvent élu par les adhérents le travail
de terrain et le contact avec les
électeurs s'effectue le plus souvent par
les adhérents et dirigeants au niveau
local il faut bien distinguer les
responsables nationaux des groupes
parlementaires à l'assemblée nationale
et au sénat et les militants de base
les militants sont souvent plus attachés
aux principes de base du parti alors que
les groupes parlementaires et les
responsables acceptant plus facilement
les compromis l'élection présidentielle
au sein de la vème république étant très
importante
les partis nationaux se sentent obligés
d'avoir un candidat présidentiable à
franges être reconnu ce qui entraîne
souvent des rivalités internes et des
clivages comme on peut le voir avant les
élections présidentielles en 2012 le
parti socialiste a innové en france en
choisissant son candidat via des
primaires citoyennes et tous les
citoyens inscrits sur les listes
électorales qui déclarait se reconnaître
dans les valeurs de gauche ont pu le
faire leur choix entre six candidats
différents
en france la liberté d'association
permet à plus de deux parties de
participer au débat politique et aux
élections c'est le pluralisme politique
en effet il y en france plus de 400
partis ou formations politiques déclaré
même si les mêmes reviennent toujours au
devant de la scène nationale
une multitude de petits partis locaux
associés à une figure politique ou à une
idéologie très précises existe le
multipartisme est une des bases de la
démocratie
il implique que les autorités acceptent
les critiques et l'opinion des autres
idéologies politiques c'est nécessaire
au contrôle des actions des dirigeants
et ça permet aux citoyens d'intervenir
librement sur la scène politique le fait
d'avoir plusieurs partis politiques qui
ont des opinions différentes et parfois
opposées devrait aider à stabiliser la
démocratie et lui permettent de
fonctionner correctement
cependant on observe souvent un
mécontentement et un désintérêt des
citoyens pour les partis politiques dans
lesquels elles n'ont plus forcément
confiance l'augmentation du taux
d'abstention aux différentes élections
montre peut-être cette réalité donc
voilà cette vidéo est terminée j'espère
qu'elle vous aura plu et que vous en
saurez un peu plus sur les partis
politiques
si vous voulez en savoir encore plus
vous pouvez aller directement à la
source sur les sites de vie publique et
par exemple le site de la commission
nationale des comptes de campagne et des
financements politiques qui sont
vraiment très bien fait n'hésitez pas à
laisser des commentaires merci à tous et
à bientôt